okay now once you've opened up that once
you've opened up that reference sheet I
want you to notice what I mentioned
yesterday namely what's there
particularly the form that it's in what
are the young cure the Aryans but one of
the necessities is a reference sheet is
that they're not going to give you each
of the formulas or quotable things in
exactly the same form that you'd
necessarily be familiar with a classic
example is a kit where the question rule
is stated the question rule is stated in
an accurate but a very abuse long form
certainly much longer see you - boss - V
- on the square
they're done that way because it's more
informative to put it that way then you
don't actually but less memorable
now the it's kind of similar for the
equation of a simple harmonic motion
they've got your I think like I said
they've got cosine there's that aside
both of that that is and they're they're
naming of the coefficients if the
constants is a little bit different but
the important thing is that you
recognize okay this is the basic form
that there are how many things can we
change with the change ever - we can
change frequency we can change we change
phase where you start from and there's
already sit we separate our frequency
which appears at the center of motion
regular so you have four things and so
this there's all clusters there I can't
remember what they need them probably a
B N and alpha I'm guessing something
like that yeah so you can call me you
aren't clearly an HSE question could
absolutely you know give them different
labels or whatever but you just
recognize those for you so you might
remember yesterday in 3d I did an
unusual thing and I think I said what I
said what I said and I said all of it we
did want to get up part of the reason
for that is because what we have a look
at these later questions there are some
weird things that are going to speak you
a little bit so I'm not a big in we
question nice so if you want to pull it
up there in front of you that would be
helpful so you're not constantly rely on
what the question is the first thing
we're going to do is interpret this
question okay because uh I've been a bit
bang on this drum that the hard thing
about everything in applications of
calculus to the physical world is
interpreting and knowing what to do I
think I just mentioned it to these guys
at the front that are in applications
calculus of this chord you're
differentiating you're integrating your
differentiate integrate usually quite
pleasant functions your Exponential's
really easy to work with trig functions
really easy to work with
and then you're substituting values and
that's it that's the Lincoln Bret like
there's very crazy weak conceptual stuff
to wrap your head around the numbers are
really easy but interpreting the words
that's high okay so read with me
question nine and as we go through I
want you to point out to me just stop me
when you find a piece of admission that
you think is worth me writing down after
the settlor question said here goes a
particles traveling in simple harmonic
motion about the origin with a ha okay
thank you first one about the origin
I'll do anything with this question
unless you know that of course when they
say about the argument what they
referring to there is the symmetry of
this movement
so that's your censure motion yes
continue going with period 24 seconds
thank you
and it puts you 220 meters okay so lots
of important details they're very dense
to say 25 to 40 120 why my w's that's
the range of version
they'll continue
initially attacked the origin okay so
let's let's turn this into some some
refreshments so at t equals when twenty
quiz you're on when T equals zero okay
so what have you the first thing I say
is initially attacked the origin so the
first thing you gonna say when T equals
zero x equals zero and that means at the
origin and then they've said a few
things it's just moving forwards now
interestingly they don't say moving you
know but they're having this attached
sign to this okay
now as a positive negative so therefore
I could attach whatever side to it I
like okay now they've said moving
forwards I supposed it would make sense
to us to define forwards as one right so
if we say this yeah
define forwards as positive okay I like
to say that what I don't just like to
say that if they don't tell me I always
make a statement of what is what when
it's something that forwards and
backwards it's fairly obvious why you
know in other cases when we have a look
at particularly projectiles and removed
and all I kind of think sometimes you
want to have things reverse from what
they normally would be makes it a
numbers easier sometimes okay there are
all our central details okay so I've got
them down let's actually start answering
these questions